un legislador quiere conocer lo que
piensan las personas de su estado sobre
los problemas de privacidad en internet
su equipo realizó una encuesta
telefónica llamando a 100 personas
seleccionadas aleatoriamente de la guía
telefónica nota que los números de
teléfonos celulares y números privados
no aparecen en la guía telefónica el
equipo llamó a esos números hasta que
respondieron las 100 personas
seleccionadas la encuesta mostró que el
42% de los encuestados dijeron estar muy
preocupados por la privacidad en
internet cuál es la principal fuente de
sesgo en este escenario también debemos
considerar qué tipos de sesgo
son más probables que se presenten aquí
un subestimado o un sobre estimado de
los encuestados y quizá no haya algún
sesgo aquí pero el no tener sesgo no es
una de nuestras opciones aquí veamos
cuáles son nuestras opciones los invito
a que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
responder esto por su cuenta consideren
lo que dijimos aquí un legislador quiere
conocer lo que piensan las personas de
su estado sobre los problemas de
privacidad en internet se tomó la guía
telefónica y cs
a 100 personas de ella aleatoriamente si
les llamo hasta que todas respondieron y
se encontró que el 42 por ciento dijeron
estar muy preocupados por la privacidad
en internet así que cuál es la fuente de
sesgo aquí vamos a resolver esto juntos
la opción de falta de respuesta hubiera
sido el caso si de estas 100 personas
seleccionadas sólo 50 hubieran
respondido la llamada y no hubiéramos
seguido llamando a los demás hubiéramos
dicho buenos 50 personas de las que
seleccionamos como nuestra muestra no
respondieron así que hubo una falta de
respuesta quizá la respuesta de estas 50
personas que no respondieron hubieran
cambiado el resultado de nuestra
encuesta pero en este caso nos dicen que
el equipo llamó a esos números hasta que
respondieron las 100 personas
seleccionadas así que de las 100
personas que eligieron se aseguraron de
que todas respondieron la encuesta así
que la falta de respuesta no es un
problema aquí
la siguiente opción cobertura parcial la
cobertura parcial se refiere cuando no
nos es posible muestrear a cierta parte
de la población una parte de la
población que quizá como no la muestre
amos nos puede introducir un sesgo
pensemos qué pasa en esta situación
somos un legislador y queremos conocer
lo que piensan las personas de nuestro
estado pero sólo elegimos a aquellas
personas cuyos números de teléfono se
encuentran registrados en la guía
telefónica así que no estamos
muestreando a aquellas personas que no
se registraron en la guía telefónica
quizás tienen números privados de
teléfonos locales y tampoco muestra mos
a aquellas personas que no tienen líneas
locales y que solamente tienen teléfonos
celulares y quizá ustedes se pregunten
bueno por qué es importante esto pues
piensen que quizás las personas que han
decidido explícitamente no aparecer en
la guía telefónica o personas que ni
siquiera tienen una línea local están
más preocupadas por la privacidad que
los demás
explícitamente eligieron no aparecer en
la guía telefónica así que la cobertura
parcial es definitivamente un problema
que tenemos aquí es una fuente
importante de sesgo ya que estamos
muestreando solamente un subconjunto de
la población total que nos interesa y en
particular no consideramos a personas
que podrían estar bastante más
preocupadas por su privacidad así que yo
diría que debido a la cobertura parcial
el 42% es muy probablemente un
subestimado de las personas que están
muy preocupadas por la privacidad en
internet ya que probablemente un
porcentaje mayor de las personas que
están aquí están muy preocupadas por la
privacidad ya que evitaron que sus
números aparecieran en la guía
telefónica así que la cobertura parcial
probablemente introdujo un sesgo que es
un 42% subestimado del porcentaje de las
personas en el estado que están muy
preocupados por la privacidad en
internet la última opción se refiere al
muestreo de respuesta voluntaria y este
sería el caso en el que el legislador
quizá haga público
o le diga a muchas personas en su sitio
web que voten por algo o den su opinión
de que tanto les preocupa la privacidad
en internet y la fuente de sesgo aquí es
qué tipo de personas entran a esa página
web si invitamos a las personas para que
realicen esta encuesta sólo obtendremos
información de un subconjunto de la
población que elige de forma voluntaria
dar esa información pero esta no es la
situación aquí aquí no se le pidió a 100
personas que participarán
voluntariamente en la encuesta el equipo
llamó a estas 100 personas para
participar en la encuesta y obtuvieron
esos datos de la guía telefónica así que
este es definitivamente un caso de
cobertura parcial